مرحبا بك تامر تامر المسحال لا ندري ماذا
نسال يعني المشهد يتكرر مع الزملاء المشهد
الان يتكرر مع اي رفيق دربي ك وائل
الدحدوح ماذا ماذا تقول في هذه
المناسبه لا نقول سوى ما يرضي ربنا انا
لله وانا اليه راجعون اي لحظات عصيبه جدا
حسن
اي تعجز في يعجز فيه اللسان عن التعبير
والكلام سوى الرضاء بقضاء الله وقدره وهذا
شاهد ما جرى اليوم مع حمزه الدحدوح ومع
مصطفى ثريا في هذا الاستهداف هو عمليه
اغتيال
لصحفيين فلسطينيين يؤدون عملهم وكما رايت
الصور كانت واضحه للعيان صواريخ تضرب
السياره المدنيه التي كان يستقلها حمزه
ومصطفى في تغطيه صحفيه في منطقه شمال رفح
المفترض انها منطقه
امنه تستهدف هذه السياره فيستشهد حمزه
ومصطفى كما اعلن حتى
اللحظه و لا مجال للخطا في في الاستهداف
لا استهداف واضح ام نقول اعظم الله اجرك
ابو حمزه واعظم الله اجر عائله مصطفى ثريا
واعظم الله اجرى الزملاء الصحفيين مشهد
صعب جدا ويعني ماذا ندري ان نقف امام هذا
الرجل سوى وائل ان نقول له يعني الله
يصبرك ويربط على قلبك حمزه الدحدوح هو
الابن البكر لوائل الدحدوح انت تعرف حمزه
ايضا طبعا الشاب
اليافع وكان
بمثابه يعني هذه الشعله من من النشاط حمزه
انهى دراسته الجامعيه من الصحافه من قسم
الصحافه والاعلام بالكليه
الجامعيه متزوج حديثا لم يمضي يعني لم
يكمل العامين على زواجه
و يعني كان ينتظر ال يعني يعني زواجه جديد
وبدا حياته وكان ينتظر في هذه المسيره من
الحياه ان يكملها انضم الى فريق العمل في
الجزيره مع بدايه هذه حرب وكان قد عمل في
السابق لفترات متقطعه مع فريق الجزيره
وايضا مع طواقم صحفيه مختلفه في غزه شاب
يافع دمث الخلق وفي وشاءت الاقدار يا حسن
ان يكتب اخر بوست وقال فيه مخاطبا وائل
والده العزيز قال حمزه انك الصابر المحتسب
يا ابي فلا تياس من الشفاء ولا تقن من
رحمه الله وكن على يقين ان الله سيجزيك
خيرا لما صبرت وقع هذه الكلمات على
حساباته
ورحل ومضى الى دربه بعد ان علق وائل على
هذا المنشور بالكتابه الله يحفظك وشاءت
الاقدار ان يودعه شهيدا في اليوم التالي
بعد ساعات قليله بعد ساعات قليله من هذا
المنشور حقيقه مشهد صعب جدا ونحن نودع هذا
الزميل وهذا الابن العزيز وهذا الابن
الوفي من اقترب من حمزه يعرف هذا الوفاء
من هذا الشاب اليافع وكثير من هذه الصور
من حفله زفافه وهذه الصوره في الحرب ل وهو
يرتدي الخوذه والدرع
ا يعني
شخصيا بعد بعد بعد الاغتيال لعائله لعائله
الشهيد عائله والد دحدوح ارسلي لحمزه على
الخاص
ف على حسابي على
الفيسبوك رساله
مقتضبه بعد استشهاد والدته مباشره وفي
الجريمه التي كانت فيها استشهاد الوالده
واخوه محمود واخته شام وابن اخته فارسل لي
قال لي عمي ابو كريم امي
ماتت يعني كانت رساله مؤثره جدا لانه يعرف
المعزه التي كانت تربطني مع عائله الزميل
وائل و والدته الله يرحمها ام
حمزه رعت مسيره حمزه وكانت تامل ان تراه
صحفيا مميزا وبدايه قبل بدايه هذه الحرب
تواصلت مع حمزه وكان هو يحاول ان يترك
بصمه في الاعلام فقلت له حمزه
نصيحه يعني من صديق وانت تعرف خاصه ان
الوالده رحمه الله عليها ام حمزه كانت
حريصه
ان يشق دربه وان يبدع في عمله خاصه انه
فتح بيته وتزوج فارادت له ان يكمل هذه
المسيره معتمدا على نفسه فقلت له حمزه انت
شاب نشيط ونشيط في السوشيال ميديا فافتح
حساب سوشيال
ميديا وافتح حسابك الشخصي وابدا انشر
منشوراتك واعمل جهدك الصحفي في ذلك سبحان
الله شاءت الاقدار في هذه الحرب ان يفتح
حسابه على انستغرام وم المنصات الاخرى
ولاقى تفاعلا كبيرا جدا
حمزه ونشر قصصا عديده
ويعني وعمل انتاجات صحفيه مختلفه اضافه
الى عمله في فريق الجزيره يعني كان
متمسكا بعمله وفيا لابيه وفيا لرسالته لكن
والله حسن والزملاء
والمشاهدين يعني لا نعرف ماذا نقول امام
هذا المشهد امام هذا القامه وهذا الجبل
وائل الدحدوح كم كان وائل كم كان وائل
فخورا
ب بحمزه وكيف كان ينظر وائل الى نجله
البكر الابن البكر الشعله
المستقبل وحقيقه يعني وقوفه بجانب والده
والده في بعد الجريمه والمجزر اللي صارت
بالعائله كان له اثر كبير جدا يعني دعواتي
ونسال الله عز وجل ان يربط على قلب هذا
الرجل وقلوب عائلات الشهداء ليس سهلا يا
حسن ان تفقد ابنك البكر تفقد الرجل الذي
وقف الى جانبك حمزه كان رجلا كان يعتمد
عليه كان مستقبلا كان صحفيا يشك الطريق
كان وائل يرى فيه المستقبل الذي يتكئ عليه
في هذه المحنه الكبيره وقف الى جانب والده
بعد الاصابه وقف الى جانب اخواته وراينا
صور الله يربط على قلوبهم يعني هذه
العائله فقدت الوالده والان تفقد الابن
البكر وابو حمزه يفقد حمزه يعني هذا
هو المصاب الكبير جدا والمصاب الاكبر انه
يرحل في وسط هذه المجازر التي تستهدف التي
تستهدف الصحفيين وتستهدف
تستهدف المدنيين الفلسطينيين وتستهدف الكل
الفلسطيني نعزي ابو حمزه ونعزي العائله
ونعزي المجموع الصحفي ولا اريد ان انسى
الصحفي ايضا مصطفى ثريا هذا الصحفي الشاب
الواعد الذي كان رفيق حمزه في كثير من
المهمات الصحفيه عمل لمصطفى لعدد من وسائل
الاعلام كان صحفيا شابا واعدا ننعى هؤلاء
الثله وهذه ال يعني الصفوه من الزملاء
الصحفيين الذين نفقدهم تباعا لا يكاد يمر
يوم ونحن الا ونحن نودع صحفيا عزيزا صديقا
مثابرا من ابناء فلسطين من ابناء غزه وما
يجري هو شاهد وهذا البوست الذي كنت اتحدث
عنه والذي يعني لاقى تفاعلا كبيرا كتبه
حمزه وشاءت الاقدار ان يرحل وتكون هذه اخر
الخاتمه خاتمه الوفاء لابيه الوفاء
للرساله
والوفاء لهذه الصوره وهذه المسيره صبرك
الله ابو حمزه الله يصبرك ويربط على قلبك
وما نراه من هذا الاحتضان من الصحفيين
وهذا الوداع حمزه لم يكن فقط يعني وفيا
لابيه بل كان وفيا لكل الزملاء كان صديقا
وقريبا الى القلب كان انسانا بسيطا انسانا
مثابرا بنى نفسه بنفسه اجتهد في دراسته
وكان واعدا دوما يتحدث عن افكار كيف يطور
من نفسه كيف يعتمد على نفسه قال انا فخور
انني ابن الزميل وائل الدحدوح لكن ايضا
انا اريد ان اصنع واشق طريم
يرحل اليوم ويترك زوجته
وشقيقاته وحبيب قلبه والده بعد ان
ودع ليس ليس سهلا على الزميل وائل ولا على
الزملاء
الصحفيين هذا المشهد الذي يتكرر معهم
تحديدا على الزميل وائل ان يودع
نجله البكر بعدما
ودع نجله محمود وابنته
وحفيده وزوجته ايضا